[Music]  the world waited for what felt like  forever  then  [Applause]  we waited longer  but this february  we promise is gonna be the gnarliest  [ __ ] ever  the wait is over  hello i'm johnny knoxville welcome to  jackie  if you're gonna be dumb you gotta be  tough  when you get knocked  [Music]  you're still blowing people up as if  life's not hard enough this guy's one  badass dude  oh man i'm on jackass is it texas rat  snake venomous  francis hits harder than any heavyweight  in the mma i told aaron it was a  lightweight  [Music]  what's the worst that can happen  [Music]  you said it wasn't gonna feel like  anything  i just need you to like sit with my  grandpa just make sure he doesn't smoke  a bunch of nasa scientists right now can  i get a cold brew  will you make him an actual coffee  stephanie  it's got to be over dude i think we're  all the way finished with spruce  stick a fork in it  [Music]  i